what is up guys my name is Jonah and
welcome to episode 16 point 5 of 30 game
programming in Java okay so here's my
idea
what I want to do is sort of like a
midweek episode after each episode and
where I sort of like show you guys like
a tape or something or basically do like
a really short like two minute three
minutes ode where I focus on one thing
because I get a lot of questions and
some of them require video to answer so
yeah so this retreat this is sort of
like a like an express episode like we
won't be actually making any major
changes to the code and what I want to
show you guys this time is how to
actually export your project as a
runnable file so that you can run it on
any computer without actually having to
you know have your code and eclipse open
because at the moment all we can do is
run it in here and that's it alrighty so
let's get started what you want to do is
hit file export and under here under
Java make sure you hit runnable jar file
hit next
alrighty now what you want to do is
select your launch configuration hit
browse and name it whatever you want
like mount mine for an alpha or whatever
now your launch configuration display is
gonna be the class that contains your
main method and mine front is the name
of the project right so select the
project that you want to export
basically hit extract required libraries
into generated jar okay so make sure
that you have the first option selected
not the second to hit finish
alrighty jar creation failed okay if we
look at this it says that the results is
out of sync now I did this on purpose
people are probably gonna be asking me
this because this is quite a common
occurrence what you want to do is if
your resource is out of sync with the
file system what you need to do is hit
cancel right click hit refresh and then
do the same process again
okay runnable jar file launch
configuration this one extracted into my
front alpha dot jar I'll just go ahead
and delete this save extract required
libraries into generated jar and hit
finish
now don't worry about warnings that
happens all the time that's cuz we've
actually got warnings in our project
that's alright hit OK now if you're over
here you should see your file right over
here now
I've on my computer it default opens
with WinRAR on my other monitor
okay now you don't want to open it with
winrar cause it's not on run what you
want to do is right click if it orbits
with WinRAR by default for some reason
open with and the the Java platform and
as you can see here it is open alright
so here we have it our wonderful game is
now in its own little window without
anything now the good thing about this
is that you can test this on any
computer which is why we also put that
FPS counter because we can't see the
console here obviously so yeah that's
why that's why we put that the counter
there and now you can do this actually
test on the different computers which
I'll show you guys in a minute alright
so now that you exported that giant
contestant on a bunch of different
systems so I'll go over on my desktop
here it's running a radio and the FPS
can really helps with that they also got
my Mac here my macbook pro for some
reason is actually running faster on
this one I do not know why this computer
is clearly better in every single way I
don't know but apparently it's just
better and then I got my old think that
so that old but as you can see it's
running about 30 is still playable and
yeah it's also it's all cool so that's
like a really cool thing that you can do
with exploding jars like you need to do
it because basically you know you don't
know what computer your clients going to
be basically playing it on so it's a
good idea to test it both on Mac on
Linux I do actually have Linux on this
computer but I couldn't be more testing
on that and I'm window so yeah that's
how do it that's how you support you
your job so you guys later and I want
one more thing if you like this Xpress
sort of like this Xpress series where I
sort of just basically in five minutes
max on on like a tip like this one I hit
the like button and tell me that you
want more because uh I'll make I'll
probably start making one of these mid
week every week so see you guys later
bye